hey what's going on guys Marcus Scribner
here and I voice bow on Chira and the
princesses of power I am gonna be doing
my first alright we're gonna shake the
bucket up don't want to see what I'm
about to pick I like to be surprised
first red carpet event ah this was an
exciting one I'm not gonna lie
nowadays I don't mean to be rude but
sometimes I just want to like see a
movie and not really walk the red carpet
but I want to see it at the premiere so
I just pull up in sweats and skip the
red carpet so now I'm like I feel like
I'm like yeah I'm a cool guy you know
what I mean like I don't have to like
take pictures and stuff but my first red
carpet experience you know that movie
planes it was like the Cars adaptation I
got all dressed up picked out my coolest
towel I love California t-shirt and went
to the premiere they had a lot of cool
like firefighter themed popcorn and all
this kind of stuff so that was my first
red carpet experience I'm gonna toss it
off behind me yeah first time watching
Shira I think was when I got the
audition
my mom was extremely excited growing up
watching the show of course my dad also
watching he-man and Shera so they were
both super pumped they're like okay you
gotta watch an episode so I watched an
episode before we ever auditioned it was
crazy seeing my character bow I was like
oh yeah I have no chance of booking this
but we'll go in there and have fun
because Bo and the original Shira was
like this middle-aged white man so it
was very different it was like hi Shira
and now it's just kind of like bows my
voice just cool all right one more I
mean not one more we're going we're
going the distance would its first role
you really wanted put went to someone
else now what a devastating feeling that
is obviously being a child actor I've
been on like a billion trillion Disney
auditions for Disney shows and you
always get up to the top and you do the
chemistry reads and you're like this is
a shoo-in I'm gonna be locked into a
Disney contract for five years it's
gonna be amazing one of the ones that I
really remember is Girl Meets World I
auditioned for Farkle and I was like
yeah dude I've got this in the end you
never end up getting them so luckily I
did in it and then ended up booking
black-ish so yeah look at that but I
don't mean say anything mean about
Disney I love you
oh let's toss this one I'm throwing this
behind I hope I'm not being
disrespectful to the entire BuzzFeed
crew I'll pick them up afterwards
see what we got when we got cooking next
and I feel like a chef over here first
incorrect rumors can you read about
yourself I'm gonna be honest the
Internet is pretty nice to me which I've
it's kind of it's insane Internet's a
very scary place recently yard there was
a story that came out of the slide guard
she's dating a middle-aged white man and
is on the show and it's like no that's
not true but I've haven't really had any
rumors before people are pretty kind so
thank you Internet don't create any
rumors after this please so horrible
throwing his behind
first big audition Castle I had a like a
small guest star role my name was Tim I
was like hey guys you want to see my
baseball cards and I was like uncle
hobby and then they took me upstairs and
I just was never seen again but that was
pretty big for me like booking that was
kind of like I was like 9 so I was like
I'm gonna be rich I was playing lacrosse
at the time I was like I'm gonna get
gold lacrosse heads like I'm just gonna
have the best like gear ever and of
course the check comes and it's like no
that was a lie first time you were
starstruck probably my top three people
that I would just like ever meet and
just like probably pass out with Drake I
mean he's our light-skinned Lord and
Savior and then we have Barack Obama the
president to go the greatest of all time
my favorite and then Kobe Bryant just
cuz the Black Mamba Lakers I mean
there's no competition so I've met
Barack Obama with my entire family at
the Easter Egg Roll heart palpitations
Michelle gives the best hugs Barack said
I was funny
it was just like there was a lot of
things happening I was kind of sick on
the day so I look stupid in the picture
didn't put my arm around Michelle I was
super awkward so I just kind of like had
it stuck you know when you have it like
stuck in between two people this is what
I look like in the picture and then
meeting Kobe Kobe also watches the show
with his family mind blown so that was
an insane experience still haven't met
Drake surprising I met Barack but not
Drake's where are you champagne poppy
with Drake no first memory from the set
of blackish it's a difficult one I
remember the first it was so awkward the
first day was
awkward we had to take like a bunch of
speck shoot photos and it really felt
like there was like it was like a prom
experience like miles would get on my
back like in a big brother pose and I
was like just for like the spec shoot it
was so awkward was all of our first
times meeting each other so everybody
was like hi nice to meet you and I was
super awkward at the time so all my hugs
were it was very it was it wasn't insane
experience that was my first memory from
the setup of blackish they've all been
positive after that but that was that
was awkward first acting credit huh it
was my first credit my mom's over there
she probably told me the first time be
be okay castle castle there is all
rotates back to Tim and Castle and the
baseball cards we've got our last one
people I mean this is this hurts my
heart but let's see what it is first
time you were recognized in public
the first billboard started going up
around the time that I was going into my
high school career so ninth grade was at
Hamilton High School was walking up the
stairs was a billboard right across the
street most embarrassing thing that's
ever happened to me but this huge like
senior stops me on the staircase he's
like yo the dude on the billboard across
the street and I was like yeah and he
was like yo that's dope man
nobody knew what the show was at the
time it was just like blackish everyone
was like okay we'll give it a chance but
he recognized me from the billboard so
that was the first time I got recognized
in public also I used to take the public
bus I used to take the blue seven down P
go then the Billboard started appearing
on the side of the buses so it was kind
of odd for me to get on a bus with the
blackish thing on the side so my mom was
like yeah we're gonna probably pick you
up from school now and that is I think
that's everything those are all my
firsts
[Music]
[Applause]